[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHAD JENNINGS: So this
is a very unique space
to give a tech talk.
I definitely didn't expect
this as I was going in.
When we were making the
slides, I told the design team
that I thought the minimum
font size was too small.
And they were like,
you know what, Chad?
Don't worry about it.
The image is going
to be big enough.
[LAUGHTER]
If you really like the
talk, you can stick around.
Avengers is on at 7.
And then at 9 o'clock,
it's the Incredible Hulk.
My name is Chad Jennings.
Thank you for joining us.
Make yourself comfortable.
This is the plushiest
set of seats
I've ever seen for a tech talk.
And for the next
47 minutes, we're
going to be talking about
HSBC's migration journey
into BigQuery.
There's no laser
pointer, is there?
[LAUGHS] All right,
so I'll just gesture
to elements on the slide.
And hopefully,
that will work out.
You can see from
the list of speakers
that we've got quite
a crew up here.
And the reason we need this
many people to tell this story
is that it's actually quite
a significant story, right?
When the world's largest
financial institution
migrates from OnPrem
into the cloud,
they're going to have some
very specific requirements
and very specific regulations
to which they need to adhere.
And that's going to
require them to do
some really innovative things.
And HSBC team has really
risen to the challenge.
And they've invented
some new technology.
And we're going to describe
that and describe their journey
to the cloud.
So if there are folks here
who are interested in data
warehouse migrations,
I think you'll find
this material very interesting.
So the cast of characters
are the following--
so my name is Chad.
I'm a product
manager for BigQuery.
And then Jan is a colleague
of mine from the Professional
Services Organization.
And he has been moving along
with Srinivas and Santa
in lockstep for
about the last year
to make this migration happen.
So that the quartet of us--
not the Beatles, this quartet--
are going to take you
through this story.
So here's how we're
going to roll it out.
Do a little bit
of an introduction
and some announcements.
We've got some new
stuff coming out.
It was mentioned
in the keynotes.
But we'll go into those in
a little bit more detail
in this session.
And then Srinivas is
going to come up and talk
about the migration
principle scope and strategy
that HSBC developed to guide
the execution, which is what
Jan and Santa will talk about.
And then we'll end it
with a, oh my goodness,
why oh why would you do
this thing, like what
are the benefits that
you get out of it?
Because it's not a
minuscule amount of work.
All right, so intros
and announcements--
first, we are aware
that there are folks
who will be joining on YouTube.
So maybe folks
watching the video
may not have all seen BigQuery.
So if you know what
BigQuery is, there
are two slides of introduction.
So pull out your cell phone.
Just put it on mute.
But watch a YouTube video
really, really quiet
or check your email.
But in two minutes,
I'll call you back.
If you don't know what BigQuery
is, then, for next two minutes,
you are my people.
BigQuery is Google Cloud's
enterprise data warehouse
for analytics.
The core things you need
to know about it is it
goes super fast over
super big sets of data.
And it also goes super fast
over small sets of data.
And you really don't
need to worry about
whether your data
is big or small.
We'll handle that
part of it for you.
You use SQL to interact with it.
Actually, I have
to update the slide
because, after the
keynote yesterday,
you use SQL and connected Sheets
to interact with BigQuery.
So SQL speakers and
spreadsheet speakers
can now interact with
BigQuery directly.
And most important on this
slide is that it's fully managed
and serverless.
And what does that mean?
All right, so in the
huge donut on the left,
you'll see a whole
bunch of tasks in gray.
And these are tasks that system
administrators or database
administrators need to
conduct to keep their data
warehouse fully fed, watered,
content, happy, and performing.
So from performance
tuning to patch upgrades,
reliability monitoring,
et cetera, that is all
stuff that Google
handles for you
if you're a BigQuery customer.
Any of our fully
managed services,
we take care of that for
you, leaving you to worry
about your business, right?
What analysis do you want to do?
What insights do you want to
try to pull out of your data?
We'll handle the rest.
All right, that was 1
minute and 42 seconds.
And I know because I'm
watching on the clock.
So if you've been off
checking your email,
come on back now because
this next set is for you.
So Google Cloud, it's part of
the information superhighway.
And a fair and
reasonable criticism
that Google has had
to withstand is, hey,
your services are fantastic.
That's the information
superhighway.
But would you please
pave the on ramps?
And so that's what we're
discussing here today
with the announcement of
the data warehouse migration
service.
So this is an agent,
or a tool, that you
can use to automatically move
data and schema from OnPrem
to BigQuery and not have
to manage that process
or not have to manage the
details of that transformation
in the schema migration by hand.
The way it works is, at
the top left box here,
is that the source,
the OnPrem system.
You actually download an agent
onto a VM in your source system
that then configures
the migration.
It looks into your tables,
the metadata in your tables,
and figures out what
the relationships are
and then posts that
back to GCP and says,
OK, I understand what the schema
should be inside of BigQuery.
Let's move it.
And then it transfers
the data over
into BigQuery using the
BigQuery data transfer service.
And then loads that
straight into BigQuery
as the same schema--
and it transforms data types,
et cetera, as the same schema
that you started
with in Teradata.
So we are very excited
about this tool.
We want our partners to use it.
We want our customers
to use it to make
it a lot easier to get their
data from the OnPrem system
to the new one.
Of note, we should say that
the supported sources right now
are Teradata, Redshift, and S3.
And we're going to be
expanding this list
as the beta continues.
We also have some announcements
around individual features.
So these were contained
in the keynote.
But let's just spend
a moment on them here.
They're relevant for
data warehouse migrations
because, if you
move, say, Teradata
to BigQuery but BigQuery
doesn't have all the features
that you're accustomed
to it Teradata,
then it won't be the
same rich experience
as you're accustomed to, like
with the brakes taken off.
So we are very
aware that we need
to make sure that
you have things
like integer range partitioning,
scripts and stored procedures.
Those are all in
alpha right now.
The BigQuery storage API is
another very significant launch
that's gone to beta.
And that actually allows
either you or any analysis tool
to get direct access
to BigQuery storage
in an exceedingly performant way
in an unlimited way, as well.
Right now, export jobs are
limited to 10 terabytes per day
with.
The storage API, you can extract
as much data as you need.
So this speeds up things like
visualization tools or data
flow and Dataproc
jobs that are running
on data stored in BigQuery.
The goal of that
API, actually, is
to make it so that
BigQuery is the place
to store all your structured
data because you can get
to it with any analysis tool
you want to once it's inside
of BigQuery.
And then launching to general
availability, clustering
is going GA, when GA
yesterday, BigQuery GIS,
and the MERGE statement.
So you can see by our efforts
here that we are continually
improving BigQuery so that, when
you migrate your data from one
to the next, that you have
all the features and all
of the speed and velocity
that you need in the cloud.
One of the things that I
think the BigQuery team
does particularly well--
and yes, I'm biased.
But I'm going to say it anyway--
is that we try to engage very,
very deeply with our customers.
At scale, we have a
public issue tracker.
And we track issues that
the public reports to us.
And so upvotes in the
public issue tracker
does move things
up in our roadmap.
So I encourage you all to use
that and upvote the features
that you want us to make next.
For platinum
customers like HSBC,
we actually get into the
weeds and design our betas
and GA requirements
the requirements
that our customers have.
I won't read through
all of these features
that HSBC is using
inside of BigQuery.
But I'll point to the
one on the bottom right.
So customer managed
encryption keys--
we actually designed the
general availability launch
requirements to match what HSBC
needed so that we could get
to GA faster for the use case
that we needed to support,
which was to please this
very important customer.
In any case, so
with that, I'm going
to kind of tie the bow in
the intro and announcements.
And talking about the
features that HSBC is using
is the perfect segue over
to Srinivas from HSBC.
SANTA DAS KARMAKAR:
Hello everyone.
Good afternoon.
This looks like a
movie star for me.
I just wanted to be speaker.
And Google made me
a movie star here.
[LAUGHTER]
So really lucky.
So my name is Srinivas Vaddadi.
And I'm a delivery
manager at HSBC.
So I lead the data
on cloud program.
And my team supports the
cloud migration initiatives.
So I just want to start
with a quick intro on HSBC.
I think many of you
already know HSBC.
But just to give you
some numbers here,
we have it on 39
million customers
spread across 66 countries.
So coming to the
data assets spot,
we have been growing rapidly.
And as of 2018, we have it
on 169 petabytes of data.
Come back to 2014,
we had 56 petabytes.
It is 300% increase.
And data centers in 21
countries and more than 94,000
plus servers, and some other
statistics on the slide there.
So going to the cloud
journey, so HSBC
has started the cloud
journey with Google about 2
and 1/2 to 3 years back.
In 2017, we started our
development environments.
And we started working on
the different requirements,
understanding
Google capabilities,
and mapping that to other needs.
And by the end of 2017, we
had a contract with Google.
And Google was selected
as a strategic partner
for data analytics services.
Going ahead in 2018, we started
building our Google Cloud
foundation platform.
And HSBC, being a very
highly regulated industry,
we need to make
sure that we adhere
to all the regulatory
policies and also make sure
that our data is secured,
addressed, in motion,
and also we have the
complete control of data.
So in this regard, we
worked with Google,
collaborated with them,
coordinated with them.
And as Chad said, some
of the features you
have seen in the previous
slides were implemented for us
to make sure that
your data is secured
and we don't have any data
leakages, data exfiltrations.
So those services
are the customer
managed encryption key,
the VPC Service Controls,
and access transparency logs.
These were really
helping us to make sure
that we have complete security
and we don't have any data
leakage or data exfiltration.
And it also helped us to
get the approvals to move
sensitive data to Google Cloud.
In parallel, in 2018, we
started analyzing our database
warehouses to see which
of them can move to cloud.
And in this slide,
you can see this
is one of our critical data
analytic workloads, which were
currently migrated to cloud.
As you can see, we being a
big international company,
we have this data
warehouse present
in more than one country.
We have at least
10 countries here.
So our approach is that we would
like to-- we started with UK.
And that is the most
complex data warehouse.
And we have created
a template for that.
And we'll use this template for
migration of other countries.
Variable-- the
regulators allow us
and Google Cloud
is present there.
So what are the
primary challenges
we are trying to address here?
So as many of the
large organizations,
HSBC has a rapid and
tremendous growth of data.
And one of the constraints
we're seeing is capacity.
On prem, we are
notable to have--
either you have to
increase our infrastructure
to meet all the data
coming in and to meet
our analytical needs, or we
need to look at other options.
And of course, that's the cloud.
Secondly, our business
is really constrained,
because I talked about
169 petabytes of data.
But what is these whole
data if you're not
able to get the business the
valuable insights they want?
So because of capacity and
processing constraints,
we are unable to really service
our customers as we want to.
Another challenge is that
these warehouses have
been built over
15 years of time,
and we have challenges to the
metadata with data lineage.
And they're causing
a duplication of data
as less data quality issues.
So to address these
particular challenges,
we started with
journey to cloud.
So the first use case I've taken
is a UK data analytic workload.
So here you can see the--
when I say "data warehouse,"
it's just not a simple data
warehouse, but
it's a combination
of-- it's an ecosystem
of the ETL jobs,
reporting jobs, and
scheduling jobs,
and analytical users using this
data for multiple purposes.
It's not a simple thing.
Just to give some
numbers to you here,
this particular UK
data analytic workload
has more than 6,500 ETL jobs
and more than 2,500 reports.
It gets data from
about 100 sources.
It has 180 terabytes of
data and a rich history
of 30 years with millions of
customers and transactions.
And also, it
supports regular data
reporting, like liquidity
reporting and the [INAUDIBLE]
reporting.
So this is a huge and a
very complex critical data
warehouse for HSBC.
And when we embarked
on this journey
of moving this to cloud, we
seeked the help of Google.
So Google partnered with us
to evaluate multiple options.
So evaluated options like
re-engineering, Lift and Shift.
And finally, we
zeroed in on what
we call as Move and Improve.
So what do you mean
by "Move and Improve"?
So we want to move our
data warehouse to BigQuery,
get all the capabilities,
and all the capacity,
and all the elasticity,
et cetera, of BigQuery.
And that helps us to solve
the capacity constraints.
That's what we are trying
to solve immediately,
because that's where we need to
either invest more in on-prem
or go to Google Cloud.
And to improve on that, we
have to improve our challenges.
So I talked about some
of the challenges,
like metadata and data lineage.
So now we are taking
this as our next task
and adding metadata,
data lineage,
et cetera, to our warehouse
on Google as a BigQuery
and making it more simple.
As far as the ETL jobs are
concerned and reporting jobs
are concerned, we talked
about the numbers there,
the staggering numbers
of 6,500-plus and so on.
So we took a conscious decision
that the primary concern
or challenge we're trying
to solve is capacity.
So we'll go ahead with
the infrastructure service
option for our ETL jobs
and our reporting jobs,
and take over ETL and
reporting as is to Google.
And also, as we are
taking this journey,
we've looked at,
how can we simplify
this particular
complete migration?
So what we did is because
this data warehouse was built
over the last 15 years,
believe it or not,
we don't have a good
inventory of it.
So we started looking at what
applications, what reports
exist in this data
warehouse and how
we can actually look
at which of them are
used and unused, right?
So we worked with
the stakeholders
and identified about
600-plus reports
are not being used at all.
So we immediately said,
this can be demised.
Similarly, we're working with
stakeholders and business
stakeholders to understand
which of the applications
are not used and which can
be not migrated, and looked
at demising of those.
So, in that way, we
are only migrating
the applications and reports
which we want to migrate.
And in this journey,
we were also
looking at simplifying
our ETL jobs
and taking off the technical
data of previous migrations
so that production support can
have a bit of sleep at night.
Coming to the core data first.
So we took the approach
of moving the core data,
core tables first.
This gives us the
data foundation,
because once we move core
data and tables on Google,
we give opportunity for
the new use cases coming.
And we use this data
developing Google Native.
And also, we are looking
at Agile and fail fast.
So we are in this
transformation journey.
HSBC has been in this
transformation journey of Agile
and DevOps for some time now.
And this project is
completely Agile and DevOps.
So we have always
looked at how we
can deliver smaller workloads
and not the bigger ones,
and how we can actually
use a fail fast,
so that we can actually
build some patterns
and proof-of-concepts and
achieve the target that we
want.
And one important thing
I want to talk about
is innovation and automation.
From day one of our journey,
we took this very seriously.
We wanted to make sure
we automate everything.
I mean, automate
everything possible.
This is very much required,
because we are looking
at a massive migration here.
And if you go with
a manual effort,
we'll not be able to
meet our timelines.
And as any other project, we
have strict timelines to meet,
because otherwise, we have
to buy new infrastructure
or renew new licenses,
which you don't want to do.
So with this mantra
of automation,
we went ahead and created
multiple accelerators.
And some of these accelerators
are the data reconciliation
tool which reconciles between
the source and the target,
using hash algorithm
at record level
and make sure that the payload
is delivered from social target
without any loss.
And where there
is a discrepancy,
we can actually
look at reporting,
and production
support can fix that.
We have one more accelator
called a SQL Parser.
So many of you know that
when we look at a Native data
warehouse, we have Native SQLs.
And they are not one or
two, but thousands of them.
In our case, there
were 3,500 SQLs.
So we don't want to
migrate them one by one.
So we did a automatic
parser, which
migrates the SQLs of Native
into BigQuery-compatible SQLs.
Third one is Data Lineage tool.
This is a very critical tool
for us, because as many of you
know, these warehouses have
been developed for the last 15
years, so there is
no data lineage,
there is no documentation.
So this tool helps us to have
a lineage between the reporting
to the data warehouse
to the source.
So it helps us to
prioritize our workloads.
As we are running
our sprints, we
want to migrate, say,
x number of reports.
We know which data, which tables
have been migrated before we
can order the reports.
And it's also useful for
our stakeholder management.
And as I told you,
the Google partnership
has been a great
help for us in this.
So as we did the transition
of moving our ETL jobs
and reporting as an
infrastructure-as-service
to Google, I think
this is the first time
anyone is doing that
in the entire world.
So we faced challenges,
many technical challenges
which we had to resolve.
And that's where we
talked to Google.
And Google partnered with
us in not only helping
us to understand the
challenges, but also
helping us to do
proof-of-concepts and building
patterns.
And these patterns are
very useful for us,
because these helped
us to really put
a factory migration in place
and not really a one-by-one.
But we have a
factory running now.
We actually migrated the
ETLs by bunches and by chunks
depending on a
workload of migration.
So, at this point
of time, I would
like to invite Jan Peuker,
who is a Google PSO Lead
and has been with us
for the last one year,
helping us [INAUDIBLE]
accelerators
with this automation.
And my colleague Santa Karmakar,
who is my Senior Tech Lead,
Technical Architect
at HSBC to take us
a little deeper into
these accelerators
and technical challenges.
Santa and Jan?
JAN PEUKER: Thank
you very much, Srini.
Even though I've heard those
numbers many, many times,
it's still
impressive, especially
on such a big screen.
So yeah, hi, everyone.
My name's Jan.
I'm a Strategic Cloud Engineer
in the Professional Services
Organization of
Google in Singapore.
Professional Services
helps our customers
with the biggest
and most complicated
technical problems,
usually through consulting,
and engineering, and very
often together with partners.
So before I go into
the details, let
me quickly explain how
those kind of data warehouse
migrations typically work.
So there's two kind
of types of customers.
There's the ones who just want
zero impact on their operations
and they ideally want
some automated tool
and just want to have
that done for them,
even if it's in an
opinionated way.
That's, for instance, what Chad
introduced with the BigQuery
Data Migration Services.
That's great.
And then there's the
other type of customers
who want to leverage as much
as possible in the cloud,
even if it means re-engineering.
And that's what Srini called
the Cloud Native approach.
Now, as we heard, HSBC
is right in the middle,
and that's why they engaged
Professional Services.
Because in the Move
and Improve approach,
we need to break that
down a little bit more.
So in order to visualize
that a little bit,
I'm going to show you
a classic reference
architecture very briefly
for data warehouses.
So those three boxes--
boxes are always great, boxes
mean architecture diagram.
On the left, we have, for
instance, an ingestion layer;
in the middle, you have
processing and staging;
and on the right, you have
your reporting and analytics,
normally.
So if we would go in
a standard project,
we would typically suggest one
of our reference architectures,
like a reference architecture
for ETL, which look like this.
You have your batch
files on cloud storage.
You get some events and
streaming through Pub/Sub.
You process that in Cloud
Dataflow for your ETL.
But maybe you're not
completely event-based,
so you still need
some scheduling
and some dependency
management in place.
Maybe you even do
ETL inside, so you
use Cloud Composer for that.
And all of that goes into our
petabyte-scale, server-less
data warehouse BigQuery.
Now, as Srini said before,
we couldn't just use that.
And Santa is going to walk us a
little bit through the details
of HSBC's more
complicated architecture
and what exactly
we did to resolve.
SANTA DAS KARMAKAR:
Thank you, Jan.
Hello, everyone.
My name is Santa Das Karmakar.
I'm a Senior Lead
Architect in HSBC India.
I'm really privileged
and honored to share
a few of my experiences in this
journey with you all today.
The current platform
is pretty complex.
It has numerous types
of free to be processed.
N number of tools are in use
and many different complex
interfaces with various
trusted source systems.
As Jan said, it
has three layers--
ingestion layer, processing
layer, and reporting layer.
Once the various feed from
the trusted source systems
arrive at the staging
areas, the scheduler at work
invokes a self-script job.
It first inserts a record
into a job control list table.
This table has a lot of
inserts and update operations.
After that, ETL tool performs a
lot of complex transformations
following business rules.
A few such transformations
like deduplication of records,
then historical data processing
based on slowly changing
dimension, snapshot load, key
generations, key lookup, et
cetera.
At the end of the processing,
it generates a load-ready file.
This file gets inserted into
our system via various DB
utilities.
We first create the
core warehouse table,
which comprises the 360-degree
view of the customer.
After that, various
aggregation tables
forms the semantic layer.
Since the current architecture
is pretty complex,
we could not use the
reference architecture as is.
JAN PEUKER: Thanks.
Thank you.
Thank you, Santa.
So if you have such
a complicated system,
what you need to do is
break down your work.
Now, again, there's two options
to break down your work.
The classical enterprise
architecture approaches
would be either to go system
by system or data by data.
System by system, meaning
you go through all
of your dependent
systems, and you just
check which ones
have to be migrated,
and you basically
make a list of all
of your dependent applications
and of your sources.
And data-driven approach
is a little bit more.
You go into the
schemas themselves,
and then you find out
which schemas are used,
and then you migrate data
by data incrementally.
Now, in this particular
project, as Srini said before,
we decided, actually,
against those two approaches,
because we wanted to
have a real business
priority and a business impact.
So rather, we decided to go with
architecture decision records.
And those would be based
on technical user journeys.
So in order to develop those
technical user journeys,
we basically did an Agile board.
I guess all of you
have seen this.
This basically looks
like a scrum board.
You can imagine those
to be user stories.
So I'm going to give you a few
examples of those user stories.
Ours that we used were much,
much further broken down,
but for the ones who know data
warehouses, some of those words
might already make sense to you.
We have mentioned, for instance,
Change Data Capture, Product
Event Handling.
We had Slowly
Changing Dimensions,
which is sometimes also called
Delta Load or Incremental Load.
Those are the typical
data warehouse topics
that you just need
to address if you
go through such a migration.
But we had some
other topics which
were more specific to the
financial services industry.
Santa briefly spoke
about deduplication
to make sure that the data
warehouse has a very, very
consistent golden source of
data at a specific point in time
that you need to maintain.
But our impact framework didn't
only base on the migration
impact.
For instance, we also looked
at the business impacts.
We prioritized the archival
data and historic data,
because that allowed us to move
already things into the cloud
and, therefore, take
load off the old system,
making the old system
faster for the users as well
as the new system.
Another impact was a cultural
and organizational impact.
Something as trivial
as SQL status codes
can be very important for
your production support teams.
So we made sure that
everyone knows them,
that we get the right metrics,
the right observability
very early on in the
process to also start
to explain to people that they
don't have to manage hardware
anymore, but now have
to manage queries,
and slots, and
performance, and quotas,
and look at very
different metrics.
That's changed, as it
takes humans a longer time.
So we wanted to get that started
very early in the process.
So, once we had those technical
user journeys defined,
we broke them further
down into POCs
and developed different
options for those POCs.
In those POCs, we looked
again at the principles
that Srini mentioned before,
but now broke them down
a little bit further into
technical principles.
And Santa's going to
talk about them again.
SANTA DAS KARMAKAR: Once
the various patterns
are identified, we establish
a few key design principles,
which we followed throughout
the execution of the project.
The current platform is aging,
and it has a lot of disruption.
With the use of various past
services such as Google Cloud
Storage for staging area
and BigQuery for warehouse,
we wanted to improve the
performance of the system.
We wanted to maintain only
a single copy of the data.
By restricting multiple copies,
we improved the maintenance
overhead, and also,
we reduced the cost.
The data is always secured with
customer-managed encryption
keys, and we also applied BBC
Service Control to prevent
the data exfiltrations.
Our consumption layer
and processing layer
are separated out.
We have used multiple
authorized views
to give access to the
data to various reporting
layers and analytical users.
With this, let me take you to
our data migration strategy,
or steps.
It has three steps.
Number 1, migrate the
AS-IS Schema onto BigQuery
and re-point all the
analytical and reporting load
onto BigQuery.
Step number 2, migrate all our
historical data onto BigQuery.
Part of the second step is
set up a change data process,
so that the warehouse system and
BigQuery always remain in sync.
Set up a data
reconciliation tool
and use metadata tagging as or
where possible and applicable.
Third step, migrate
the data access layer
by converting all
the SQL script into
BigQuery-compliant scripts.
This seems to be a very, very
long and time-consuming task.
To speed up the development
and reduce the human error,
we introduced a lot
of accelerators.
Here we are going to talk
about four accelerators today.
The first accelerator, Schema
Parser and Data Reconciliation
Tool, helps us migrating our
data layer onto BigQuery.
SQL Parser helps us migrating
the data access layer
onto GCB platform.
And Data Lineage tool
provides a dependency
across various components
in the pipeline.
With that, let's look
into these tools.
I will combine the Schema
Parser and Data Reconciliation
tool in my next slide.
And here it is.
From the source system,
we first extract
all the table
definition information
and create a Avro
Schema Parse file.
And then we fetch all the
records from a specific table,
and we convert them
into Avro format,
load it into a data file.
While doing so, we also apply
hashing perform operations
and create a hash data.
Load that data into
a different file
along with all the
key elements in it.
We call this as a Passport file.
Once the hash file,
and the Passport file,
the hash information, and
the data files are created,
we load this into
GCS using GS util.
From there, we execute
VQ load command
to load the data into BigQuery.
If the tables are not created,
first, you create the table.
Then the data gets loaded there.
Once the data is
loaded into BigQuery,
we again apply the
same hashing operation,
but this time, we
do it on BigQuery
and get the hash value.
And then we compare
the hash value
with the data, what
we have received,
using the Passport file.
Whatever differences,
discrepancies are there,
it gets reported into
our reporting layer.
And our products
and support team
finds it quite useful
to correct this data.
This tool is quite
helpful and very quick.
With the help of
this tool, we could
reconcile data for
a specific table
in a couple of minutes, which
generally takes almost an hour
if I want to do it manually.
It has consistent and
repeatable processes,
which eliminates a
lot of human errors.
Audit is enabled in every
operation in this tool.
Moving the historical data onto
BigQuery is quite an easy task.
But when we are moving the
changed data on every devices
to sync my on-prem data
warehouse with BigQuery,
we need to set up a change
SED type to operations.
So that was a little
tricky for us.
When you are migrating
a small table,
it's just a one-step process.
But if it is a big table, we
need to migrate the data chunk
by chunk.
So once we have migrated
the data layer successfully,
then we look at how can we
migrate the data access layer.
What would be the strategy?
How can I bring a
lot of parallelism?
That is what cloud is known for.
For that, Jan is going
to talk about it.
JAN PEUKER: Thanks a lot, Santa.
So as Santa just
said, we couldn't just
take the easiest approach.
So once we had our
technical user journeys
and we had broken
down the decisions,
we could have just
done different POCs
and decided for
whatever is the easiest.
But the goal was--
Srini's goal, really, was
still to Move and Improve.
So we still wanted to get
a faster time to insight.
We wanted to get high
availability and higher
performance.
So we couldn't just take that.
And to illustrate
that, I'm quickly
going to show an example based
on surrogate key generation.
So in your regular relational
database or data warehouse,
you generate surrogate keys
typically using a sequence
or some kind of row identity.
Now, we could have also
still generated a sequence,
but ordering stuff manually,
monotonically increasing,
there's always a bottleneck.
There are some academic
solutions around that,
but the fact is if you
do that somewhere, it's
going to make stuff slower.
Now, BigQuery is fast,
because it parallelizes.
So we wanted to find
a solution that we
can parallelize while
still maintaining
full consistency
of our batch loads
and make sure that
reconciliation is successful.
So how did we do this?
We did this using UUIDs.
Now, I used the
word "hash" here,
because we're actually not using
the UUID function in BigQuery.
We're actually hashing
multiple columns
that redefine as key columns.
The trick here is-- there's
actually two tricks.
One is we're using the
information schema in BigQuery
to find those key columns.
And to find the
schema itself, we
worked very early in the alpha
and beta programs together
to use the information
schema functionality.
And the second trick was
to use a MERGE statement.
Now, you would wonder,
we're just inserting,
why do you want to merge?
Ignoring now the history
processing itself, but
if I just insert new values,
why do I need to merge?
The trick here is the merge
has an update if it matches.
In that update, I
can throw an error.
And now I know exactly
which roles don't match.
So I don't actually execute the
merge, but I throw an error,
and that gives me
exactly the information
of which rows and
columns are matched
and which are a problem
in the actual process.
Now, once we had that solution
and working very fine,
we actually found that we could
also solve another problem.
In some data warehouses,
you have a feature that's
called Unique Set Tables.
It's a rather obscure feature,
in my opinion, that allows
you to basically ignore errors.
You just insert into a table,
and if something is already
there, it doesn't
actually insert.
It basically automatically
deduplicates.
We don't have that
in BigQuery, but we
could use the same solution.
We could just define all
columns as a row identity
and then apply the
same process again.
Just, in this case, it would
be the other way around.
We would just not do anything
if there was already a match
or insert a new record.
This way, we could leverage
the full parallelization
of BigQuery when
ingesting the data
while still maintaining the
highest snapshot isolation
level, and the full audit lock,
and the full reconciliation
capability, knowing, at
each exact step, what we did
and what happened.
With that, I'm going
to go back to Santa,
who's going to explain how we
automated that whole process
inside the SQL Parser.
SANTA DAS KARMAKAR:
Thank you, Jan.
So BigQuery and
on-prem warehouse,
they are not the same
syntactically and semantically.
So existing SQL script
in current warehouse
does not work as is on BigQuery.
For example, delete star
from a specific table
works perfectly OK in
most of the RDBMS system.
But in BigQuery,
it does not work.
You need to add an additional
WHERE clause at the end.
Few data type such as small
int, CAD, worker, et cetera,
there is no direct
mapping in BigQuery.
However, good news
is in BigQuery
you have similar data type
with higher precision.
Example?
String and n64.
So there is no
data loss when you
migrate the data from existing
warehouse onto BigQuery.
The time table or
volatile table deconstruct
are actually different in
these two environments.
So SQL Parser exactly
identifies all the scenarios
from the existing SQL
script and converts them
into BigQuery-compliant scripts.
With this script,
we could improve
the performance, the development
effort by 50% to 60%.
There are many such
scenarios we have identified
while going during the
development phases,
and we all included them
into the SQL Parser as
and when we found it.
It's a very quick tool.
Easy and super helpful tool.
With that, let me take
you to the last tool
for today's discussion.
That is Data Lineage.
This tool is actually a scrum
master's and project manager's
delight.
What it does, it discovers the
components from various layers
and identifies all the
dependent components,
starting from the ETL feed
to ETL jobs, then warehouse
tables, and packages.
So scrum master
finds it quite useful
to identify only the
dependent component which
is required for a
specific MVP in a sprint
and allocate the work.
How it works?
It picks up a reporting
file as an input,
identifies the corresponding
tables from there,
which ETL job
populates those tables,
and then what are the
ETL feeds required
to populate those ETL jobs.
A very super helpful tool.
With the help of this
tool, we could also
eliminate the various
integration issues
because the dependencies
across various components
are actually identified
right at the planning stage.
Along with that, this
tool also helps us
for the stakeholder managements,
where we have big metrics
and we know whom to contact
when you are migrating
specific applications.
With this, I will
hand it over to Jan.
JAN PEUKER: Thanks again, Santa.
Yeah, so the biggest
benefit for us and for me,
personally, was really that we
could work so closely together.
We developed a lot
of those tools.
We gained knowledge.
We could work together
really on the keyboards.
And yeah, we developed features,
as I mentioned before--
not only CMAC and
VPC service controls,
but we worked in information
schema, the MERGE statement,
all of that hand in hand.
The other benefits are going
to be covered by Srini again.
Thanks so much, Srini.
SRINIVAS VADDADI:
Thank you, Santa.
Thank you, Jan.
This is a great discussion.
So what are the
benefits of doing this?
And I just want to cover that.
So faster processing.
So we all know that we
are going to BigQuery now.
And we observed that a job which
took one hour or more on prem
is taking less than
10 minutes for us now.
That means we are meeting
and exceeding SLAs.
The unified data
consumption layer.
Because as Santa said,
we are maintaining now
a single copy of
data on BigQuery,
creating authorized
views for each consumer,
and then choose a
parallel onboarding
for consuming applications
that helps us to even federate
our development and testing.
And the flexible capacity as
flexible, scalable capacity.
As you know, BigQuery
is scalable and elastic,
and this is providing the users
with the great benefits of pay
as you consume.
So simplified
warehouse platform.
So we are actually ending
up with a much simplified
warehouse platform.
As I talked about, the
Move and Improve approach
and the rationalization
of applications
we talked about
before, as well as
the way we are simplifying
our ETL jobs as we migrate.
So, in summary, we
have taken this journey
of migrating our UK data
warehouse to BigQuery or GCP.
And we used the words
"Move and Improve" approach
for migration,
collaborated with Google,
and embraced open source.
And automation has
been our main focus.
And we are taking the
automation to the next level
by building many accelerators.
And potentially, we
are working with Google
to open-source accelerators.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
CHAD JENNINGS: All
right, so I hope
everybody heard that last
part, because migrations
is one of the PM
responsibilities
that I maintain on
the BigQuery team.
And, as I go to talk to
customers about things that
are keeping them up at night or
making them worried about doing
a migration, reconciliation
and code migration
are very much at
the top of the list.
And so the last point
that Srini meant
is, like, the
possibility that HSBC
would be able to open-source
these tools, I think,
is going to be a really
impactful change.
So hang on, we'll get
to that in a little bit.
I wanted to invite you
all also to ask questions.
We've got about five
minutes left here.
But I wanted to leave kind of
with this high-level thought.
We've worked incredibly closely
together over the last three
years to get HSBC into the
spot that they're in now.
And we really wanted to
motivate to all the--
Google is really good at
making new technology happen,
and customers are really
good at guiding us
into saying, hey,
we need technology
to solve this problem.
No, not that thing over
there, because that's
too bright and shiny, Google.
We need you to solve
this over here.
And that level of
collaboration and partnership
has been really, really
valuable for both Google
and for our customers.
And so I wanted to
make that point here,
and hopefully you've
seen evidence of that
through the story that the
gentlemen here have relayed.
[MUSIC PLAYING]